it's got to be astronomical because
everyone's running something to get to
the rim well it's only our what four
fifth game and we weren't over uh cox
pavilion as matheran knocks on the
triple from the right ty jones couldn't
grab it chris duarte does
lob for matheran nice recovery to put it
in
wired in that trade as well exactly so
halliburton healed
obviously
you've got bathrooms a big time shooter
duarte
[Applause]
nice hesitation step back dropping it in
for benedict matheran
a really good run as a coach at detroit
in dallas for many years
and now on the rebuild in indianapolis
and you know whose staff he was on in
portland
great offense
loose balls 50-50 matthew collects it
gets his feet underneath him this is
just a gift his ability to get himself
collect himself and knock down threes
[Music]
uh it's hard to see it's hard to watch
and you you were there and you said it
was fairly graphic it was yeah i
was looking away when he went down
he's got the ball in his hands right now
with three and a half minutes to go
gonna make a run at the hoop
get two more on the ledger for matthew